before we get started with today's video
i do want to mention another channel
that i host called business plays it's
about business except it's really not
it delves into communist plots crazy
people from florida terrible social
media campaigns
and pretty much whatever else danny the
writer on that channel decides that
he has cobbled together for me that day
in a sense business place is pretty much
the exact opposite of biographics of
throwing a good amount of silliness and
fun at you along with some facts
people are so dumb it's really
remarkable oh you're so dumb
there are also some premium grade a
memes included so check it out through
the link below if you're feeling curious
and
in the mood for something different and
let's get into the video
to an artist there is no greater degree
of success than
the mononym michelangelo basquiat
madonna to need only one name means that
you
are a legend in your field you are more
than just known
you are foundational you are the
blueprint that future generations build
upon
even if you don't get your own ninja
turtle for most of his career rembrandt
painted frankly rather unattractive
people in an age of instagram filters
it's hard to see the appeal of looking
at
well this so what made him famous in the
first place and why did he fall out of
favor just as his fame was reaching
its peak the story of rembrandt is rife
with the same kind of drama he's
captured on canvas there's passionate
romance heart-wrenching tragedy and a
redemption arc that ultimately ends in
betrayal
buckle up because today's episode is
going to get a touch shakespearean
[Music]
one of ten children born to father
harman garritzun van reen and
mother nielsen viltsa dota van so
good lord zutiya broke only six
survived rembrandt harman zun van rin
was number four
and he was chosen out of all of his
siblings to attend latin school
they were a family of millers and van
ryn actually refers to the river that
they lived next to the rhine rembrandt's
education focused on biblical studies as
well as greek and roman classics this
clearly had a big impression on the
young lad because they would become the
subjects of
most of his celebrated works however the
wonders of the ancient world failed to
hold his attention
quite as much as painting and at the
tender age of 14 he asked to study the
craft at leyden university he
apprenticed
under two masters jacob van swanberg and
peter lastman van swonenberg is best
known for his paintings of hell and here
is where rembrandt learned how to play
with light and reflections
last-minute painted historical epics the
kind of paintings you think of when you
see
old important paintings naked people
tangled up in sheets startled horses
crumbling architecture men with swords
stabbing horses
people respected these pieces because it
demanded a thorough knowledge of not
just the human figure but also
landscapes animal life and ancient
architecture there's no way to hide any
gaps in your own expertise either
you know what you're doing or you go
down forever in history as the genius
who painted a lion with sideburns
as of late 1625 rembrandt settled in
leiden and began work as a
guild-certified master of painting
his early work draws heavily from
glassman's historical work
though immediately rembrandt sets out to
experiment with the composition of not
just the visual elements of the painting
but the physical composition of the
paint itself
he painted fur and feathers by adding
extra linseed oil to the pigment making
it thin and
applied it to the canvas with a brush
holding only three or four bristles take
a look at this wealthy fellow with
the delicate feathers in his cap and the
shining orchard and his neck even the
scepter under his arm bespeaks a
quiet reserved aristocracy at first
glance he might not look exceptionally
wealthy but to the upper crust of
amsterdam subtle elegance was the mode
of the day
what was once an unimpressive backwater
had been transformed almost overnight
into the country's foremost trading hub
tobacco farmed on new world plantations
arrived by the boatful along with fine
silks and exciting new diseases
and well with that came money the first
patrons to support rembrandt had grown
up poor and suddenly experienced an
explosion of wealth in middle age or
later they didn't land about in saloons
or pubs the church was their foremost
social venue so
people had to master the art of the
subtle flaunt or risk total damnation
sumptuous furs understated jewelry
delicate lace work and embroideries
these fine details were what his
customers wanted so he set out to
showcase the art of expressing human
expression his etchings and sketches
especially capture
almost spontaneous moments of emotion
how the face crinkles during a laugh the
weight of sadness that accumulates in
his mother's eye here is the artist
who shows us as we are not as we would
have ourselves look
honest and unstaged he used the term
natural liveliness to capture the kind
of accidental unrestrained
motions normal to real life but absent
from static images he also
took in some of his first students
including gobert fink an ambitious
history painter whose
untimely death would play a part in
rembrandt's final humiliation but we'll
get to that later historians estimate
that at least 50 individuals spent time
with rembrandt which in part explains
how
many works have been falsely attributed
to him though the official count now
ranges between 300 and 350
the tally was once much higher google
still claims 600 unique works to the
master but that's just not right google
he was famous for his self-portraits
scribbling off over 40 portraits and 37
etchings leading
some fairly desperate journalists to ask
if he invented the selfie absolutely not
but let's take a look at an early
example and see what made them so
compelling to the public
here we see the artist in his natural
habitat look at the rough floors the
cracked plaster the shabby clothes he
worked in
notice how small rembrandt himself is
compared to the foreground canvas
every detail is meant to convey this
noble simplicity a dignified austerity
rather than humiliating poverty but look
at this mysterious aura
glowing from the canvas intentionally
turned away from the viewer his eyebrows
seem to be raised but his expression is
unreadable
he sees something we do not he knows
something that we can only guess at
the glow is heavy with possibility
mysterious emanations of light are a
recurring motif in rembrandt's work
almost always representing some kind of
divine blessing no matter how you slice
it this is
tantalizingly sassy here we have the
perfect summary of his early career
because shortly after this he would
begin experimenting with dramatic
shadows
in 1630 rembrandt uprooted himself from
the university town of bladen and headed
for the burgeoning metropolis of
amsterdam where
the money was just piling up this was
the start of the dutch golden age where
crushing poverty and conflict was giving
way to
a burgeoning new passion for science and
trade a ceasefire in the 80 years war
had been negotiated a decade earlier the
dutch republic had managed to establish
itself people were ready to start living
large
dutch style he was already pulling in
commissions from the hague and selling
to princes when he moved so he had
little trouble finding representation
with the dealer hendrick van ulenberg
the two shared accommodations and three
years later rembrandt
would marry hendrick's cousin saskia van
ulenberg
as is generally the case with marrying
an artist her family had some
reservations about the 29 year old
rembrandt saskia's father had been a
wealthy burger master
and had left behind a considerable
inheritance socially she
towered above him he grew up in a mill
house she was the darling of the
political class
defying convention she demanded a speedy
betrothal and in 1634 they were wed none
of rembrandt's family decided to show up
which is ominous because it certainly
didn't slow down the young couple in
1639 they bought one of the most
expensive houses on jordan breestrat
which
of course you know as the broadway of
amsterdam and they filled it with art
and uncomfortable fancy furniture
rembrandt's career was
red-hot copies of his work were turning
heads all across
europe and he was cranking out more
commissioned portraits than ever
everything the kids touched turned to
gold and as we all know once you're
successful nothing bad can ever happen
to you again
ever so he started spending like his
status depended on it obviously it would
be sacrilege for me to call one of the
foremost european artists a gold digger
however with his multiple incomes and
saskia's considerable inheritance they
could have paid off the mortgage with
a handful of frugal years instead
rembrandt hit the town
paying handsomely for imported asian
weapons pretty rocks and
antiques which sprawled throughout his
impressive estate fun fact it stops
being a sensible business expense at the
point where it impacts your ability to
repay your debt but we'll get back to
that later what impact did this sudden
wealth have on his work
[Music]
earlier in the mid 1630s rembrandt had
reinvented himself
he stopped signing his work rh and
instead added the famous d to his first
name
his work got physically darker dominated
by looming shadows punctuated by
clusters of lighter shades he called
these clusters kindred colors and
it acts to draw focus like a flashlight
on only the key details
in an artist in his studio the light was
evenly distributed throughout the whole
piece the canvas and
figure are given equal weight only
relative size indicates the scale of the
room
let's compare that to the apostle paul
in prison and immediately
you can see the difference the light
envelops in paul leaving the walls
behind him in darkness
the parchment along with the white shirt
collars draw our eyes to his hands and
face in the shadows next to him tucked
behind a stack of books glints a
formidable blade we get the impression
that the saint has abandoned the will to
war and
is instead investing himself in
scripture here
light and focus are interchangeable the
details are illuminated in descending
order of importance
we can read the whole image with just a
glance before
narrowing our attention onto the juicy
bits
in 1639 rembrandt was commissioned by
cotton merchant and part-time militia
captain bennett to
produce a guard room scene of his
company the kloveneers the sort of
musketeer they trained in the use of the
aquabus which
sounds more like architecture than a
firearm but it was a firearm rembrandt
earned a cool 1
600 gold gilders for the commission
which he used to build an addition onto
his house large enough to contain his
massive canvas while he worked on it to
understand why this painting is so
groundbreaking let's put it in context
the war's front line was several
thousand miles of ocean and a formal
ceasefire away
none of these men were in any danger of
actual fighting these militias were
funded by rich debutants in the same way
that tech ceos now buy basketball teams
they weren't soldiers
in the likelihood that they ever had to
face combat they probably would have
fled to their secondary homes in the
country
it was just an excuse for society men to
abandon their family empires for a
weekend and
drink with their mates in the woods to
commemorate their fun times together
they would commission portraits of
themselves to hang in their fancy
clubhouses
here's an example of a traditional
guardroom scene now while these
certainly look like two rows of soldiers
polished up nice for a school photo
do they really feel like soldiers or are
they just well groomed heads on top of
nice clothes is
soldier something you are or is it
something you do
imagine that these dead and lifeless
rugby lineups are what you expect art to
look like
and then someone shows you this your
expectations are
absolutely shattered the horizon of the
possible widening beyond what the
audience can imagine and swallowing them
whole this is what the artist does
they take the normal and they blow it up
it's important to stress how physically
large this work is the figures of the
captain and lieutenant are as big as
their real-life counterparts and the
only reason
it currently measures 12 by 14 feed is
because monsters cut off a bunch of the
sides
pictures cannot really capture the grand
size of this thing here we have captain
bannek along with 18 of his loyal
citizen soldiers spilling out of the
city gates ready for action for ease of
reference i'm going to call this piece
the night watch the leap from guard room
prom photos to this action-packed movie
poster
is like the switch from listening to
your grandpa's war stories as he falls
asleep in an armchair
to watching apocalypse now on imax
nothing else in the gallery could even
come close to the action
the movement the sense that these
soldiers were going to march
right out of the frame and capture the
snag table this
isn't just a picture of people being
these are men
witnessed in the midst of doing and
there was simply
nothing else like it at the time
arranging people side to side gives them
a sense of equal weight and importance
rembrandt
flipped the script on that and framed
his piece front to back with
the leaders clearly in the forefront
surrounded by a halo of their troops the
captain is flanked on both sides by
glowing individuals almost like
parentheses
in the edges and corners of the worker
busy and crowded darkness
villain is a literal example of the
lancer a
tv trope's term for the second in
command he's clearly got that lieutenant
ryker swagger with his brilliant clothes
and on a weapon the perfect image of a
glorious soldier the lance's blade is
painted roughly to
make it pop from the surface look how
convincingly it's been foreshortened the
shadow seems to cover a portion of the
bottom of the frame you can imagine him
lifting it aloft and
shouting charge but see how the shadow
of the captain's hand falls over his
clothes
the placement is a little salacious but
we don't need to dwell because the hand
is actually holding a lion with a
centendries cross the
city's emblem the message is clear the
lieutenant does not outshine his
commander
every gesture every detail conveys some
significance about their relationship
in contrast the captain's clothes are
black safe a brilliant sash of scarlet
and a collar that helps
frame his fearsome visage the captain
isn't concerned with the vanities of
fashion he
needs his mind clear in order to
safeguard his troops but wait is that a
little girl and she's got a dead chicken
on her belt
either she's out of place or war in the
17th century was much stranger than it
is today
in actuality this is rembrandt engaging
in a dan brown-esque symbolism a habit
he would explore more heavily in his
etchings
the claws of the chicken are taken from
the clover near coat of arms and
the chicken itself is upon our cock's
name the dutch word for
archwas was clownier in fact bird claws
are also present
on the chain of the amsterdam company of
aquabuses a trophy worn by the winner of
that year's award but she's also holding
a goblet next to an oak leaf both images
significant to the cloven ears
clearly acting as a kind of battlefield
mascot does the girl's face seem a
little mature that's because
rembrandt has hidden saskia in there so
how did the public react it's popular
clickbait to state that the night watch
was rejected and this collapsed
rembrandt's career but the truth is a
lot more complicated than that before we
get to that fallout and why it
definitely doesn't involve any secret
murders let's talk about the other
issues in his life
in the midst of their dramatic rise in
society saskia and renbrand tried
multiple times to start a family
only their fourth child titus survived
infancy shortly after his birth in
september 1641
saskia fell ill probably with
tuberculosis and rembrandt started
having an affair with
gertie dix their maid saskia died on the
14th of june 1642 the same year the
night watch was finally released plot
twist her will stipulated that rembrandt
would
lose access to titus's trust should he
ever remarry while still dallying with
gertie started wearing hendrick
starfalls his second maid who was also
20 years his junior outraged gertie sued
for reneging on his promise to marry her
she pawned some of cesky's jewelry which
rembrandt had given to her so he had
committed to an asylum then hendricker
was excommunicated from her church and
this all happened in just one house now
you know why artists
touch popular subjects for historical
romances the drama
is apparently very juicy
[Music]
the popular narrative claims that the
night watch was rejected almost
immediately which combined with the
tragic loss of skaskia and
three of his children supposedly sent
rembrandt into a spiral of despair on
the contrary there's no proof that the
night watch was ever actually rejected
bit hung in the club in his clubhouse as
intended now it is true
that he painted no portraits in the
decade after but he may have simply
refused all commissions rather than
not have been offered any in the first
place he focused on sketches and
etchings instead he did have to use
legal measures to compel one subject
andrei deschaff to pay having to defend
the merits of his work to a court of
peers clearly irked him as he used this
episode as inspiration for a sketch
depicting everyone involved as a group
of asead hooligans while
rembrandt defiantly wiped himself with
their opinion
classyfellow obviously a change took
place but the scale and emotional tenor
had been
exaggerated somewhat for the sake of a
more compelling story
if there's any one external factor that
hurt rembrandt it was the fruit of the
dutch golden age the children of
rembrandt's original patrons had
returned from their fancy international
rich kid daycare schools and they were
ready to party the peacock generation
craved sensual experiences rich foods
glitzy clothes loud parties and
they rebelled against every aspect of
their parents stoic simplicity they
wanted nothing to do with rembrandt's
saggy cheeks and oppressive shadows
that was no way for a princess to look
they imported the nascent classical
movement from france which
suddenly made rembrandt's dodgy realism
seem all the more drab
he didn't become unpopular he just
became unfashionable his work was
considered praised up until his death
even if it didn't keep up with the
trends
another misattributed detail of his
legacy concerns the so-called
rembrandt brown an almost gauzy earth
tone present over much of his work
most of that is varnish added after his
death in order to smooth out the effect
of impasto
thickly applied paint that manipulates
the play of light on the surface
varnishing flattens the effect making
the work readable at a wider range of
distance the
kind of thing you might care about if
you were a gallery owner trying to get
the most eyes on the work as possible
the night watch suffered the most
initially it was a daylight scene but
the thick varnish blotted out much of
the color
history automatically isn't brown and
grimy some museum curators simply
chose to ice skate uphill at one point
in history it was so heavily varnished
that it successfully deflected a knife
attack the ultimate truth
of his fall lies not in some existential
crisis inflicted by the loss of his wife
but
rather the fact that he was difficult to
work with his contemporaries joked that
he would not interrupt his painting to
meet with a prince and
no matter how respected an artist you
are having that kind of precious
attitude is going to cost you
talent can elevate you to the upper
echelons of society but cannot compel
power to kneel in every endeavor if you
are unlikable your prospects will suffer
the antisocial geniuses too important to
bother with social niceties tend to only
be appreciated after their deaths
because
no one can abide their company while
living talented
wealthy jerk you tend to only get to
pick two
on top of his train wreck of a personal
life debts and spending continued to dog
him until he died
on july 15 1656 he declared bankruptcy
adding insult to injury the chamber of
insolvency where he made his case had a
doorway crowned with a marble carving of
rats crawling out of an empty money box
his house and possessions were sold at
auction but they failed to fully cover
what he owed the only surviving piece of
furniture a huge mirror an ebony frame
broke on route to the new house even
after downsizing to a modest cottage his
obsessive collections would again grow
to fill two large rooms his bankruptcy
stripped him of his guild membership and
the ability to work as a master artist
so he only managed to continue painting
by setting up a dummy corporation
wherein he was the sole employee
to add insult to injury he was
technically owned by his then lover
hendricky and
son titus so how did a man with
rembrandt's ego cope
why two years later he painted himself
dressed like a king and
well you've just got to respect that
move
[Music]
one of the most consistent themes of
rembrandt's later works is how he
blurred the line between finished
painting
and sketch rembrandt knew how limited
the cone of visual focus really is and
how much detail the human mind fills in
around it at the distance his paintings
are seen he knows exactly where he has
to place the fine brush strokes and
where he can let us do the work for him
he was very touchy about
letting people get too close to the work
because he knew the effect would be
ruined he often joked about the
offensive smell of the paint but
that didn't stop him from cleaning the
brushes on the coat that he was wearing
perhaps the perfect example comes from
this painting of hendricka storefalls
when taken as a whole it looks like a
normal complete painting maybe a little
on the saucy side with those bare thighs
and
plunging neckline but you wouldn't call
this unfinished would you
let's zoom in on her hands though what
happened here it looks like she tried
boxing a meat grinder
her thumb is a single brush stroke
compare that to where her leg enters the
water and the reflection it casts below
her
look how fine the detail is when his
critics claim his work is incomplete
they're pointing to contrasts like this
but if the artist decides it's
finished why does it matter that they've
left the unimportant details rough and
cursory the hands clearly
aren't the point of the picture we don't
need to see every branch and
leaf in the foliage behind her because
they're not relevant it's not a portrait
of a river
it's a portrait of someone bathing the
dirty old man wanted to
paint his new flame in an intimate
moment and from this
we got a work of immense genius
we know him now primarily for his
paintings they never left the
netherlands in his lifetime and he is
one of the few master artists who never
studied outside the country of birth
in life his international reputation was
built almost entirely from his line work
producing over 300 etchings and over a
thousand sketches
to this day he is considered one of the
foremost masters of etching having
invented new ways of playing with line
shape and thickness even the physical
composition of the resin he etched into
every aspect of his craft was done with
intent always prodding
at the absolute limit of his tools he
would work on the same print
for years at a time releasing drafts
even as he continued to make sweeping
changes to the composition
bankruptcy put an end to his etching so
in a mysterious twist none of his tools
or originals were sold at auction
they simply vanished perhaps sold
earlier on the sly or given to a friend
for safe keeping either way the majority
of the plates that had been destroyed or
lost by the time of his death though
82 have since been rediscovered
remember govert fink one of rembrandt's
early students
he had gone on to establish a
respectable career producing technically
competent histories and portraits his
life relatively free of conflict or
strife he was commissioned to paint a
series of 12 canvases for amsterdam's
new town hall
a mix of biblical stories and scenes of
mythologized dutch history after
completing a set of preliminary sketches
he died suddenly and the commissions
were divided between his contemporaries
despite being out of favor with the
elites rembrandt was chosen to depict
the conspiracy of claudius civilis where
a former roman soldier
united the disparate tribes and drove
the roman army out of the rhine
it's a story intimately familiar to the
entire country marking the birth of the
dutch identity
nascent liberation from spanish rule
added an extra layer of significance to
the story which was experiencing a
popular resurgence at the time
it's like king arthur but real that's
how important the story was to
rembrandt's audience so
of course he was going to play it safe
and not offend anyone
right that's certainly what the burger
master assumed
here's how otto van veen painted the
scene in 1613. it's technically
competent but
conceptually bereft there's no surprise
no shock of the new it
wouldn't be out of place in a textbook
here's rembrandt's version looking like
an early magic the gathering card
never before had sevilla's empty socket
been depicted so centrally
until then the tradition was to only
show him from the side
and the soldiers surrounding him were
grizzled and haggard like real soldiers
these weren't the enlightened
philosophers who would
usher forth a united nation these were
flee bitten murderers used to
sleeping in a saddle the sword oath was
a detail invented by rembrandt himself
see how the light seems to bubble up
from the painting itself it hung
briefly before being returned with a
vague request to make it more
presentable he probably wasn't ever paid
for the work commissioned on a custom
curved canvas measuring
over 30 square feet instead he cut out
the heart slapped it in a smaller frame
and
tried to mark it just the central bit
four fifths had been lost a time saved
for the enigmatic sketch on the back of
a funeral invitation an outsider was
hard to complete think sketch to hang in
its place and
slap together a replacement in four days
rembrandt was unable to find a buyer and
set up to sell saskia's grave
his chance to come back came and went
hendricka died in 1663 titus went in
1668 and his father followed one year
later so i really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below don't
forget to subscribe and thank you for
watching